the fact that Rand Paul was the guy who  stood up and filibustered John Brennan's  nomination says a lot about where we are  where are all these serious Democrats  you know who believe in civil liberties  where are the people that originally  were against John Brennan because of his  statements on torture you know they're  nowhere so I give you know I don't agree  with Rand Paul and on much in the world  but I give him a lot of credit for  having the spine to stand up and say you  know for one day we are going to stop  business as usual and he read into the  record serious reporting for the first  time ever said the names of US citizens  who've been killed in operations  authorized by President Obama but the  fact that it's someone like him doing it  instead of you know Democrats who spent  so much time under the Bush era  condemning these very same things says a  lot about how bankrupt Congress is on  this and other issues